bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france d'abord est-ce que
la fermeture des frontières partiel ou
pas c'est une mesure efficace pour
lutter contre la pandémie a séparés
j'apparais du bon sens dans la mesure où
la contamination se fait par le porteur
humain du virus
il est bien évident que plus on limitera
les contacts venant notamment des pays
où il y a les variants mieux on se
portera
c c'est un effet le bon sens évitant
évident il faut éviter la
démultiplication des contacts puisque
c'est par le contact que la contagion se
fait je crois que c'est pas la peine de
deux de sortir de l'ena et vaut mieux
même ne pas en sortir pour faire ce
constat alors il ya longtemps qu il ya
longtemps si vous permettez ya longtemps
qu'on aurait dû du reste prendre la
décision de fermeture des frontières à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne mais
pour des raisons probablement
idéologiques voire même certainement
idéologique parce qu'en france le mot
frontières fait peur on a tardé tardé à
établir des contrôles et pendant qu'on
tarde et bien birhus lui passer la
frontière
est-ce qu'on réfléchisse au niveau
européen néanmoins quand même à modifier
les règles de circulation entre les tirs
oui bien sûr bien sûr mais cela se fait
avec tout le poids de 2 de l'idéologie
immigrationniste peu au lieu de voir la
frontière comme une protection naturelle
ici contre le virus
on l'a investi de toute une idéologie
qui qui qui n'a pas sa place et qui fait
que même quand on est confronté à une
pandémie on a encore des gens qui
viennent vous dire mais le virus n'a pas
de passeport
je dis que c'est tellement bête parce
que le porteur du virus lui il a un
passeport bon donc progressivement on se
fait à l'idée que la frontière est
devenu un bouclier naturel qu'il faut
savoir utiliser on voit l'exemple belge
avec une frontière une fermeture
partielle des frontières on voit que des
exceptions notamment pour les
travailleurs c'est vrai qu'on se dit
aussi que la fermeture des frontières au
niveau européen cela peut être aussi un
sérieux obstacle à l'activité à
économique et ça peut aussi freiner
certains pays on peut le comprendre
aussi
oui bien sûr et la belgique limite la
belgique interdit les voyages dit non
essentiels pour je crois que eux toute
application catégorique avec aucune
ouverture d'applications intelligentes
d'une d'une décision peut avoir des
effets pervers
il faut donc se réserver toujours une
clause d'adaptabilité posé le principe
que les frontières sont fermées mais le
accepté des clauses la libre dames la
stabilité dans le cas par exemple des
frontaliers qui vont travailler tous les
jours devraient être de gay soumettre à
période régulière à des tests voit pas
il faut essayer de faire une application
intelligente de normes contraignantes si
on le fait pas c'est vrai qu'on est dans
une forme d' aveuglement en un règlement
juridique ce qui n'est jamais bon dans
la vie pratique lorsqu'on a du mal à
comprendre
gilbert collard c'est pourquoi
finalement les pays européens avance en
rangs dispersés 7 sentiment que l'on a
quand on voit la décision prive en
belgique l'allemagne aussi réfléchi a
fermé son espace aérien aux destinations
internationales
et pourquoi il n'y a pas de décision
commune au niveau européen pourquoi
c'est si compliqué mais puisqu'elle pas
d'euros c'est tout c'est tout il y à une
europe de des lobbys il y à une europe
de 2d des industries les entreprises du
cac 40
il ya une europe du fric mais ya pas une
europe des citoyens
c'est tout le monde l'europe n'existe
pas là n'a fait la preuve avec avec
cette pandémie et elle devrait du reste
tirer les leçons humaine de cette
pandémie pour quitter cette gangue
bureau technocratique profondément
boursière profondément métalliques pour
entrer dans la reconstruction des
rapports humains
là l'europe pourrait peut-être devenir
ce ce supplément d'âme européens dont on
a besoin alors qu'est-ce qui me boutique
tenue par quelques personnes quand vous
pensez que les députés européens n'ont
pas accès aux contrats qui ont été
signés entre eux l'union européenne et
les laboratoires pour les vaccins oui la
démocratie là enfin quand même bon en on
est traités par cette administration
comme des comme des objets en et ans on
n'est même pas ce sujet de l'union
européenne en est objet de l'union
européenne et s'agissant de la france
justement on réfléchit à confinement pas
de confinement on ne sait pas dans le
coffre à attendre la semaine prochaine
et un conseil de défense
aujourd'hui pour l'instant on n'évoque
pas du tout l'idée d'une fermeture des
frontières par parcelle de limiter les
déplacements
les frontières devient progressivement
bien fermé faut quand même le dire je
pense qu'on va aller vers un ver
confinement parce que les l'application
des tests fonctionne mal on a pris
beaucoup de retard
on n'a pas la quantité suffisante on en
gère la pénurie les variances montre
quand même très inquiétant
on a en a du mal à savoir quel effet le
vaccin pourrait avoir sur eux
le responsable du caue de la vaccination
en france et très prudents ils
s'inquiètent même du fait qu'on puisse
pas avoir les deux doses on est dans une
situation qui est très critique et
malheureusement faute d'avoir pris
toutes les mesures peut-être pédagogique
instinct formation de 2,2 de protection
on en a plus que la solution arkalyk 1
du confinement ce qui est ce qui est
désastreux pour l'économie ce qui est
effroyable pour le psychisme
mais bon on en est là qu aucune réaction
à ces personnages avant de conclure une
réaction sur cet accord conclu entre
sanofi et et phaser biotech sanofi qui
devrait aider le laboratoire justement à
produire le vaccin
oui mais non mais qu'est ce qui permet
tout ce qui est une bonne chose
tout ce qui permet d'accélérer la
production du vaccin est une bonne chose
mais quand on quand on acte qu'il faut
accélérer la production du vaccin il
faut avoir l'honnêteté de dire on est en
pénurie on n'accélère pas la production
de quelque chose que l'on a en en dose
suffisante bon c'est bien que on sait
bien que les doses manque
or là encore ça fait partie vous
comprenez la solution du confinement
c'est la solution 2
de deux la capacité
on est dans un pays qui est tenu par une
bureau technocratie quand vous pensez
que avant qu'une décision soit prise sur
le plan médical
sur le plan de la santé publique il y à
au moins 17 agences qui doivent donner
leur avis je dire s'il ya un comédien au
comité a créé c'est le haut comité de
l'élimination des eaux administratifs
inutiles parce qu on est on est
paralysée par à une administration dans
dans sa hiérarchie je dis hein parce que
les les petites mains font un travail
admirable mais on est paralysé par le
totalitarisme d'une administration
tatillonne borné lente qui c'est la
guerre entre alain qui qui ne se
communique pas les informations il
faudrait qu'ils arrêtent de se battre à
coup de tampon il ya il y a un enjeu
d'intérêt national et il faut qu'on
arrive à fluidifier la décision à
pouvoir passer par dessus les
difficultés pour répondre à les médias
t2 du danger que cette pénurie constitue
merci beaucoup à vous un geyser collard
d'avoir répondu à nos questions mais
rien que vous êtes député européen